[Música]
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony brinque en visitó las
zonas afectadas por el terremoto en
Turquía al tiempo que anunció un apoyo
por 100 millones de dólares de
Washington para Los afectados en suelo
Turco y también en suelo sirio
finalizó en addisa beba la Cumbre de la
unión africana los líderes del
continente discutieron herramientas para
disuadir a golpistas en el Continente al
tiempo que pidieron más apoyo a la
comunidad internacional para enfrentar
la violencia ampliamos desde la capital
etíope
Río de Janeiro vive un carnaval especial
sin restricciones por primera vez en dos
años hoy conoceremos más de la historia
del sambódromo de esta ciudad inaugurado
en 1984 y con capacidad para 75.000
personas ampliamos desde Río
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos
tras participar en la conferencia de mi
unígena Alemania el secretario de estado
de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken visitó
el este de Turquía devastado por el
terremoto del 6 de febrero en conjunto
con el noroeste de Siria el jefe de la
diplomacia estadounidense anunció la
concesión de 100 millones de dólares de
ayuda suplementaria a Los afectados por
la catástrofe
acompañado por el ministro de asuntos
exteriores Turco el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken llegó a
la base aérea de incierlich aquí donde
se está entregando parte de la ayuda
humanitaria para las víctimas del
terremoto del 6 de febrero todavía
marcado por las imágenes de destrucción
en la provincia de atay que acaba de
sobrevolar el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense vino a mostrar el apoyo
de su país
cuando es la magnitud de los daños el
número de edificios el número de pisos
el número de hogares que han sido
destruidos para ser necesario un
esfuerzo masivo para reconstruir y
estamos comprometidos a apoyar ese
esfuerzo vamos a Añadir 100 millones de
dólares para ayudar a quienes lo
necesitan desesperadamente
una ayuda que se suma a los ocho cinco
millones de dólares y a los helicópteros
enviados por los Estados Unidos para
entregar alimentos y suministros de
Socorro a las víctimas
del 6 de febrero también se han
desplegado 200 socorristas
estadounidenses para ayudar a encontrar
supervivientes pero casi dos semanas
después de la catástrofe Turquía ha
anunciado que dejará de Buscar excepto
en las provincias más afectadas de atay
y caramanás un anuncio que alimentará
desesperación de quienes aún no han
encontrado a sus familiares
mi primo sigue bajo los escombros la
búsqueda debe continuar para encontrar
al menos su cuerpo
este terremoto es la peor catástrofe
para la Turquía contemporánea solo en
este país han muerto más de 40.000
personas y cientos de miles quedaron
damnificados
Hablamos ahora de la guerra en Ucrania y
nos vamos al frente Oriental actual
epicentro del conflicto los recientes
combates entre fuerzas rusas y el
ejército ucraniano han sido crueltos en
buledar pero también a los alrededores
de cupians y bahamut allí Moscú Busca a
toda Costa tomar el control y el
Ministerio de defensa ruso se ha
atribuido victorias parciales en zonas
como krasna ahora el informe es de
Samuel Salgado
estos soldados ucranianos patrullan una
aldea cerca de la ciudad de bacmut
pertenecen a la unidad Witcher
Ok el frente ruso se encuentra Solo dos
kilómetros de estas calles cada
movimiento de tropas es perceptible y
representa una amenaza
One
una escena que hace parte de la batalla
por bacmut la más Sangrienta de la
guerra hasta el momento según el
presidente ucraniano bolo de mirtelevski
a pocos días del aniversario de la
invasión Rusia necesita resultados y la
conquista de bacmut es uno de los
principales objetivos en el frente
Oriental
Jenny líder del grupo paramilitar ruso
Wagner preveía tomar Bad mood en
diciembre el año pasado pero la
descoordinación entre el kremlin y la
milicia retrasó hacia la ciudad los
rusos planean conquistar bakmuth en
marzo o abril
la ayuda armamentística de la otan ha
equilibrado las fuerzas en bakmut según
el comandante la brigada 45 artillería
ucraniana el 50% del armamento que
Ucrania dispone actualmente ya es
occidental más sofisticado que el
soviético usado por Rusia
las fuerzas rusas intentan avanzar todos
los días
pero funcionan de manera caótica no
tenemos pérdidas
cosmar nombre de guerra este soldado
batalla 176 kilómetros de backmud en
copians
a pesar de su entusiasmo las noticias no
son buenas para Ucrania aquí el
Ministerio de defensa ruso se atribuye
nuevas victorias en dirección a jarkik
la más reciente rankifka los residentes
de la zona en guerra desde 2014 solo
quieren una cosa vivir en paz
vamos a África porque finalizó en
Etiopía la Cumbre de la unión africana
una cita en la que los líderes del
continente hicieron un llamado a la
comunidad internacional para una mayor
cooperación contra los grupos armados al
tiempo destacaron que la falta de fondos
y el Coby 19 estancaron la lucha contra
la malaria la organización además reveló
que se encargará de organizar el proceso
de diálogo y Reconciliación nacional en
Libia desde adiza beba mariam cone
periodista de France 24 nos amplió la
información
será la conferencia más inclusiva desde
el comienzo del conflicto libio desde
los dos gobiernos del país hasta los
actores de la sociedad civil incluidos
miembros del Antiguo gobierno como los
hijos de cadafi también será la primera
vez que una conferencia de
Reconciliación nacional se celebran en
el territorio libio debería tomar forma
en breve ya que es Divisas presidente
iniciador de la propuesta ha pedido que
la conferencia se celebra antes celebre
antes de junio de 2024 siguiendo con las
cuestiones de seguridad la unión
africana área afirmado que no quiere
levantar las sanciones de Mali porque
juntas militares fruto de golpes y
estado y como novedad la cdo ha
prohibido a sus dirigentes viajar en
estos tres países en cuanto a los demás
puntos en la Cumbre de la unión africana
se dieron pocas respuestas no hubo
fechas ni medidas sobre claras sobre la
puesta en marcha de la zona del libre
cambio intercontinental de la zona libre
cambio continental que era el tema de
este cumbre en sus discusión de clausura
los presidentes no dieron ningún
resolución para este Cumbre y evitaron
hablar de temas espinosos como la
elección del vicepresidente de la unión
africana entre Marruecos el Argelia y
seguimos en África porque este domingo
se materializó el fin de la cooperación
militar entre burkina faso y Francia
después de que el gobierno militar de
Ibrahim traoré exigiera La retirada de
las tropas a finales de enero los
militares Galos salieron paulatinamente
las protestas contra la presencia
militar francesa fueron recurrentes en
los últimos meses priorizando las nuevas
alianzas con el grupo Wagner ruso que ha
ganado peso en la región más detalles en
el informe de Marta Moya
fin a la presencia del ejército francés
en burkina faso después de que el pasado
22 de enero el gobierno del capitán
Ibrahim traoré exigiera la salida de las
tropas galas este domingo se hizo
efectiva la petición en una ceremonia de
la que no trascendieron apenas imágenes
burkina siguió los pasos de mal y en su
determinación de cerrar la cooperación
militar con Francia una decisión
celebrada por muchos no queremos que se
queden ni un minuto más necesitan salir
de nuestra burkina faso no los queremos
en nuestro territorio porque cuando
están aquí muere nuestra gente no hacen
nada
desde el golpe militar que puso a traoré
al mando del país el pasado octubre las
relaciones con el gobierno de Manuel
macron se deterioraron
estamos aquí para mostrar nuestro
Patriotismo Mostrar nuestro apoyo a la
transición Mostrar apoyo a nuestro
ejército Mostrar apoyo al Capitán
Ibrahim traoré
algunos de los gobiernos africanos han
venido priorizando la presencia del
brazo paramilitar del gobierno de Rusia
el grupo Wagner en su lucha contra el
terrorismo una alianza materializada por
el canciller sergei labrov en sus
recientes gira africana
vamos a prestarle nuestra ayuda para
superar estas dificultades esto afecta
Guinea burkina faso chat y a la región
del sahel en general la cooperación
entre Rusia y estos países de África
también fue uno de los puntos clave para
que macron pusiera en noviembre fin a la
operación barcane operativa desde 2014 y
que llegó a desplegar a más mil tropas
en la región desde París aseguran que la
decisión no marca el fin de las
relaciones bilaterales pero sí supone Un
paso atrás ante la avanzada de Moscú en
el Continente Corea del Norte y le danzó
este domingo otros dos misiles al mar de
Japón en lo que pión yang calificó como
una respuesta a los más recientes
ejercicios militares conjuntos de Corea
del Sur y Estados Unidos en un
comunicado del régimen norcoreano Indicó
que la frecuencia de sus ensayos con
proyectiles dependerá de los movimientos
militares de Washington en América
Latina varios mandatarios de izquierda
le están dando la espalda Dina boluarte
en Perú cuyo gobierno también es de
izquierda pero sea Aliado con la derecha
para mantenerse en el poder México
Colombia Bolivia o Argentina han
expresado su preocupación por el
encarcelamiento del expresidente Pedro
castillo y el abuso de la fuerza
policial en las manifestaciones
anticobernamentales Alba Santana nos
amplía
es un rechazo generalizado de los países
con gobiernos de izquierda en América
Latina hacia el gobierno de transición
de Perú presidido por Dina boluarte el
último roce diplomático fue con Colombia
tras que el congreso peruano declarara
personalón grata al presidente Gustavo
Petro por criticar la acción policial
contra los manifestantes
el Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
toma nota de la moción del Congreso de
la República de Perú interpreta que es
un acto de carácter político del órgano
legislativo de Perú que no compromete al
pueblo y por tanto no afecta la
histórica relación con la hermana nación
Asimismo reitera su confianza en que la
democracia y el estado de derecho se
impondrán en el Perú pero este no ha
sido el único desencuentro del ejecutivo
de boluarte con naciones de izquierda
México Bolivia Argentina o chile han
cuestionado el encarcelamiento del
presidente Pedro castillo y la represión
policial en las protestas de las últimas
semanas motivo por el que el presidente
de México Andrés Manuel López Obrador se
negó a entregar la presidencia rotativa
de la alianza del Pacífico a Perú le voy
a dar instrucciones al secretario de
relaciones exteriores que le notifique
este
a los miembros
del grupo de Río qué hacemos
porque yo no quiero entregar
este a un gobierno
que considero espurio Bolivia llegó a
publicar un comunicado conjunto con
México Colombia y Argentina sobre la
preocupación por la detención y
hostigamiento antidemocrático a Castillo
algo que Lima tachó de injerencia
política Aunque lo cierto Es que ante la
negativa del Congreso peruano a convocar
elecciones cada vez más naciones de la
región le están dando la espalda vamos a
Río de Janeiro que vive un carnaval sin
restricciones tras dos años y vamos a
hablar del sambódromo del Marqués
sapucaí fue inaugurado en 1984 y tiene
capacidad para 75.000 personas esta
fiesta cultural de suma importancia a
nivel económico puede mover unos 871
millones de dólares Valeria sacone
corresponsal de France 24 en Brasil nos
amplía los detalles
hoy empieza en el sambodromo la
competición más importante del carnaval
dos escuelas de samba aspiran al título
de campeón seis se presentan esta noche
y aquí en el bastilla al lado del
sambódromo es donde se preparan las
escuelas porque cada una tiene hasta
3.200 miembros y hay que formarlos en
alas para que puedan salir a la hora
exacta en el lugar correcto
es normal está todo el mundo corriendo
en los barracones entregando los
disfraces cociendo cosas que se soltaron
arreglando cosas siempre hay un poco de
atraso Pero al final todo sale bien
gracias a Dios
imperio Serrano es una de las escuelas
más tradicionales del carnaval de Río de
Janeiro ya fue campeona nueve veces del
grupo especial pasó muchos años en una
situación difícil sin dinero este año
está volviendo al grupo de élite del
carnaval Y tenemos mucha fe en que vamos
a quedarnos aquí es nuestro lugar
es más que cultural es algo que
transciende a nuestros ancestros en
realidad heredamos esta fiesta de ellos
y nosotros solo la estamos perpetuando
a categorías como los disfraces la
canción la obra como un todo porque un
desfile en el sambódromo es como una
ópera itinerante que se puede ver en 360
grados entonces cada detalle importa así
llegamos al final de esta informativo
aquí en France 24 Les agradecemos su
sintonía quédense con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]